so I
I guess this will be a little decoration
for this Workshop
since the the main goal of this uh work
is uh uh trying to understand the
holography and the space-time symmetry
it's a space-time geometry but you will
see that this is very related to the
topics you heard earlier like tensor
networks and
entanglement so uh the motivation of
this work is basically some very basic
thoughts about space time geometry in
Quantum systems and their relation to
holography so what I will call permanent
understanding to holography you will see
is very poor
and then uh so so uh then I will after
the motivation I will talk about what
exactly uh I have done so so the
definition of what I call that exactly
exact holographic mapping and uh
applying that to uh some very simple
free formula uh it's but so the the
general uh the general procedure is you
start from uh a boundary Theory which is
uh some very ordinary uh
system like a free formula and analytics
and then you try to map it to a new
basis and then in a new basis you can
read all the geometry which which can
have different geometry depending on
what state you start from
and let me give you a way to uh to prove
the interesting geometry is like a black
hole and then we will discuss in the end
I will discuss the uh interacting
systems
so uh so just a very brief
uh
overview of the background which is the
holographic Duality so uh
so Colorado Duality was first proposed
in string theory context starting from
this paper alcohol and moncina and the
other two important works then uh this
observation from the student theory that
there are different series which are
which are actually the same which are
due to each other and the different
series are super yummier's theory on one
hand say four dimensions and then the
gravity theory in five Dimensions but
then the reason why this become more and
more interesting and the charismatic
there is also a physics also got very
interesting in it is that it also it has
a a more General
understanding so the interpretation
there is a more General interpretation
proposed which is that this this Duality
is related to renormalization group
which is also related to my Approach so
uh so so it was proposed that this
additional Dimension uh in the Dual
series is like a renomination group and
the equation of motion is likely
normalization group equation in very
vague sense then uh then the the
photography
because it's like a generalization of
renormalization group it may give you a
way to uh
to describe the the strongly correlated
systems
then
so but but uh so far most of the
approach is like I write down the Balkan
binary series and compare them and it's
not like I started from a boundary
Theory like I give you a hamiltonian and
the ground state and then try to
construct the bulk Theory the gravity
try to construct it from from the
boundary Theory so there are efforts
along this line and and what I would
describe today is also an effort along
this direction which is means you try to
construct this folk and understand what
do I mean by having a gravity deal of a
theory in a boundary
uh
so I would like to start from some very
basic questions when we try to
understand the geometry what do we mean
by geometry in the general Quantum
States so we know following uh general
relativity that In classical mechanics
the In classical world the geometry
means now means the remain manifold so
we have points and then we have the
audacity distance between points
so now if we want to generalize this uh
this uh point and distance Concepts to
Quantum systems then there are two
questions how do we Define points in our
geometry and how do we Define distance
between points of course there are in in
general there can be many more structure
other than distance on the geometry but
we are just taking the simplest one
that that exists in the Riemann geometry
so so then uh here is a roughly
my proposed understanding to these two
questions which we will become more
specifically later so so I want to
understand Point as uh as just a direct
product decomposition of hero space so
basically you have a system if I just
give you a hamiltonian which is a matrix
in some bases and the ground level
function then that doesn't specify
anything about basis choice so you may
write down your will functions in
momentum space or real space right so in
a different basis Choice which to be
more precise a basis Choice means a
direct product decomposition say I
decompose my herbal space into
into the hero space of every site then
whenever you give me this the
conversation then that defines a set of
points every Factor space is a point
which may be momentum
and so
not necessarily there are different
points you may in general you may have
different parts I won't have different
points but uh but uh yeah in general
I don't see
why you have they have to have the same
Dimension but uh then uh okay so so then
this choice is very arbitrary because I
can choose momentum State space points
or real space points uh but so so then
uh why some of the choices are special
this is related to the second question
about distance between points so uh so I
don't know how to define distance
between policy in general I don't know
what's the general principle but but I
believe there is a some very general
requirement of your definition of
distance which is it should be a
function of physical correlation
functions in the system
this is basically just just trying to
trying to describe the relativist
relativity principle in this Quantum
system it says that the distance between
two points shouldn't be something given
by an exterior external measure but it
should be determined by the Dynamics of
your universe
whether it should be some way to measure
it if you live in the universe
space I assume it has a hamiltonian yeah
so so so so so I I don't want to
describe any system that that we don't
know how to described by by our economy
kind of so let's assume it's just a
standard Quantum antibody system with
the hamiltonian and it's either in the
ground state or it may be an excited
state so in any case it's a it's a
well-defined Quantum motion and then uh
the question is if you just look at that
system uh how to define geometry then
then I want to say that you you make a
choice of this decomposition and then
you measure the physical correlation
functions between these different points
and then use that to determine the
distance and then you can ask whether
that's a well that's a reasonable
measure if you get somewhere in a local
correlations then that means this is not
a
good choice of geometry so um so okay so
what do I mean by using the correlation
functions to determine
that is your defining locality by where
the correlations are strong
so if things are strongly correlated
they're close by so how can you get
Coalition instead well no to be more
precise it's not a getting correlations
that are not close by but it's like
getting some
uh
some points that are
like you may get a distance which which
which is far from the riemanned geometry
distance we are familiar with like
everything is close to each other or
something like or everything is far from
each other you may get some geometries
that are very pretty defined so that is
it's not useful to describe it as a
geometry
uh you can but uh I I don't want
something that only depends on
hamiltonian because for the same harmony
with different states I can I they can
still have different geometry
like I have the same Harmony of my
universe but but I can create some
matter
and depending on the energy of this
matter I think a different geometry
so it should be something that you can
both come with me and
and the statistic
okay so in general I want this uh
there's a distance to depend on physical
career function and if two things are
more correlated then they are closer to
each other so so now I want to translate
that into a formula how do I do that
let's consider some very simple states
of matter which is massive States uh all
these states that has a short run
incorrelation so we know in general it's
uh it's not uh proved in general it's
not proved that children declaration and
the mass Gap are the same thing but
let's take some state which has children
decoration
then uh for example we can just consider
this mass mass uh massive free formula
so it's some timer right the chain like
a formula Hawks on this chain with the
diamond right hopping then there is a
map if there is no damarization then
it's nice list so then when you
calculate the correlational function and
decades externally if there is a mass
then uh okay so now uh if I I cannot ask
if I live in this universe uh what do I
use what's a natural way to measure a
distance then you simply you can simply
just back out just just reverse this
formula and say okay I can use this log
of coordinate function as a distance so
when this correct one detects majority
of distance that means if you if you
define your distance in this way at a
long distance limit as a long range
large scale you just recover The
Familiar euclidean geometry and you can
generalize this uh also to time
direction if you allow me to use the
imaginary time real time I don't really
know I still don't really know how to do
it because there is an oscillating
correlations in imaginary time there is
a Decay also you cannot help decay in
this career function so you can use the
same formula for the distance between
space time points
so so okay so so now if we restrict
ourselves to massive States then there
is a reasonable definition of distance
which we know recovers our familiar
geometry at a long distance this Co is a
real number
oh this one yeah in general uh in
general is not so this is probably I
should uh I should use some absolute
value so so actually if I use Mutual
information I avoid this problem so so
what uh well if I only look at the
spatial uh for different functions then
there is a way to avoid this choice of
what career function you choose so
otherwise it sounds ambiguous maybe some
Korean function is very children and
there is another one hidden that you
don't know that has very large
correlation so mutual information uh
helps to solve that problem so in this
work of Matt Hastings and collaborators
they show that the admission information
uh which is defined as the entropy of
the two sides subtracting directory of
them together uh that that's a bound
there's an upper limit the upper bound
of correlation function so if you
calculate this and this indicates
expanded in some way then you are
guaranteed that nothing indicates slower
so so then you can use that as a basis
independent measure of equal time
correlation and then I put that instead
of a c in this formula yeah
defined distance
element of some operators in the
hamiltonian between those two states so
is there a reason you don't want to use
that definition uh as I asked her to uh
I I said earlier the I don't want to
define something that's unliable
functional hamiltonian
you can have different states say ground
state or final temperature they
correspond different geometry so so this
special correlation between two points
is not only a function of hamiltonian
but also a function of the state you are
in your definition only depends on the
stage my definition well if you
calculate the different time correlator
it does depend on Hamilton the equal
time of course is determined by the
state at that time
so
there are other questions
so this Mutual information was only a
space not a space-time music space so
actually it's a interesting question in
general like how do I generalize this
result that moving on making the equal
time curator is it possible to
generalize that to space-time
correlators is there a function I can
calculate which generalize this
information and the people mean
I don't know the answer and that's one
thing we're trying
it may be also some other state so for
any given State I want to read out the
geometry so so G can be any instead
you're interested in
and then uh well if it's a different
time then it's not only a function of
the state but also the time evolution
so uh okay so so far so good uh it gives
you a geometry definition for uh for a
capital state so but it's something
funny happens when you go to capital
states so so so in the Gap State say you
have some spin system living on this uh
this flat space then you define the
distance then it recovers the flat space
metrics in the language in a large scale
so there is this triangle inequality
XD plus z y is equal to x y but when you
go to a critical State imagine imagine
you live in this universe so you don't
have another ruler to measure distance
you just measure the Korean function and
then use this definition to measure a
distance now if your system goes across
the phase condition and the mass becomes
zero you get parallel correlations like
this
uh if you only win an Universe you you
won't be able to know whether this
Behavior change comes from a change of
geometry or comes from a change of
Dynamics on top of some geometry so if
you if you still use this definition you
will see you will get a different
definition of distance
uh which now looks like a lot of the
flag stress distance
okay so so if you live in a universe you
may conclude okay I already obviously
I'll change it to something like that
it's a distance between two points
becomes shorter the girl is lower but
but if you think a little more then you
you realize some more conclusion than
that you realize that it's not only a
change of geometry like in a sense of
changing the arena Magic from the flat
one to a curved space it's not like that
because there's no metric which will
give you this distance
why because if you look at the triangle
inequalities
three points XYZ then it's true the time
when you call it is still true so DX Z
plus d y z is bigger or equal to X Y but
you never take the equal sign because
the log function is
is always bigger than x y even if they
are even if they aligned on the same
straight line which means the
differences are they minimize but they
still find it so so for any remote
geometry you always have glsc right so
you can always take the third point
along the geodesic so that the equal
sign statement
so this tells me that even if you just
live in the universe it tells you uh
there is some way to tell that that this
this uh that this this geometry is not
really a remote geometry anymore
so so there are so you can do different
things maybe you just admit that uh that
I have to Define like geometry in a
different Mass but uh but if you try to
relate this uh this observation to what
is to the real geometry that you are
familiar with then uh one way to one
possible solution is that that you can
try to find a new basis as I said a
choice of a set of points uh is a set of
direct direct product uh decomposition
of the human space so there is no a
priority way to do that so in this real
space uh in like in this example you
have been taking this obvious or this
naive choice of a real space which is
what is given from your uh your your
theory you just call that like uh
lagrangian or hamiltonian and then you
use this uh this real space that we are
familiar with but uh in this kind of
case where the real space bases give you
uh uh we are the geometry then it's
possible that you can transform to a
different basis and Define a new
geometry there and this is exactly the
proposal I want to make that in this
critical systems there is a way to find
this a unitary marking which brings you
to this new basis where the geometry
becomes the remote geometry again
and then and then the way you do it is
basically you build this new direct
Dimension and then you find the new
geodesics such as okay now you
understand that this traveling quality
problem is solved because because all
the geodes will go through there is no
dimensions that's exactly why this
holographic Duality is natural for this
critical State even if we don't
starting from some special serial
experience here yes if you want to do a
differential geometry we need a metric
but we also need a way to parametrize
the manifold so we can take partial
derivatives
how are you parameterizing well so far
everything is discrete so I I don't
really know how to define differential
structure but uh different uh core
different parameters I mean different
coordinates on the on the manifold I
think it's part of the choice of basics
like you do a choice of basis means a
way to decompose the human space and
then you can you can do the same
decomposition but label the size in
different way so so as a very special
special case of this different choice of
basis uh is a coordination information
so I want to define a rieman sensor I
need to take derivatives of micro
transfer with respect to some very
important taking care of just with
respect to
but you label your size and if you
really have a Continuum limit which I
believe we have but I want a real space
position
what do you call it real estate so so
what you call it must be depends on the
depending on the new basis
but maybe that will become clearer later
because I mean basically you need to
Define this unitary mapping which
defines the the basis and once you
define the basis uh you know what you
what do you mean by a real space point
or what do you mean by an operator
leaving on any given time and once you
know that you can take
so
so so
um
uh so in summary what uh what what we
have learned so far is that that this
naive real space Choice which is given
by when you write down the hamiltonian
you call this real space this naive
Choice may not be the best choice
because that may give you a very uh that
when you have a long correlation then
this the geometry you define is not so
local so but you may be able to find a
new basis and then now I want to Define
what uh propose uh this new basis at
least we know how to do it for some very
simple series and that uh we hope it
works for more generosity so so let me
describe uh how do I Define this this
basis uh basically say say your 30
position is this a one-dimensional chain
and uh in general it may be interacting
uh I will take I will describe the
system I will really study is a free
formula but in general this definition
works for your driving system so you
have this one-dimensional chain and you
may this can be generalized to higher
dimension so so yeah so you take this
chain and then you define the unitary
mapping which is given by the triangle
here this unitary marking would you map
there's two sides in the two other sides
and then uh these two other sides uh one
of them is labeled color blue uh red and
the other one the black one goes to the
next layer and then you you repeat this
process so basically uh physically what
I want to do is I want to define the
unitary marking so that so that this red
one represents uh high energy degrees of
freedom of these two sides and then the
black one represented oil is equations
of freedom and then so that's like a
normalization group but now I have
promote this normalization group to an
exact mapping because I didn't throw
away this highly integrated or freedom I
just separate them so that I keep track
of the energy scale but I didn't throw
away anything or trace or anything so
then you take the laundry one and split
it again to high energy and low energy
so so this whole network is a
combination of a bunch of this unitary
Transformations so in the end you get a
uniform written in accurate space
so so so in the end the combination of
this whole network is a is a unitary
transformation from this blue size to
the red dots the number of blue and red
is the same
and and uh and then this this is a
modification of mirror I will explain in
two slides uh well exactly was the
generalization here
so
okay so this is just a moral cartoon
view of the same picture so so this this
layer
which is covered is this tree this tree
Network so the three Network I draw in
the last is this this one and and you
input this size when you you have these
two sides coming in and then there is
this one going out of the out of the
plane uh which is the Red Dot and the
other end goes on that layer and
eventually everything goes out of the
plane so so so this defines this new red
Red Dot basis uh which is just a basic
transformation to the old one so so so
like in the other basis You Will Call
some operator here as a local operator
and then you can calculate Korean
functions but if it's a mass list Theory
you see this correlation function
indicates that the parallel and better
now uh so the claim is that by defining
this new basis you can find that the
correlation function between these
points are actually more local because
you have separated different energy
scales yeah so in this mirror
construction there's also this
disentatives
because I I don't want to uh because I
don't want to assume the different sites
are are artists entangled so I don't
really need the details and tumblers but
in general well I don't really need this
in hamburger here but in general I may
it may be good to have them
right so so that's really it yeah so I
should explain that uh the relation to
Mira so so the relation to Mira uh state
is so Mira is an Einstein State and so
so here here this network this orange
color layer is a unitary mapping so it
doesn't specify any state although
although you would like to apply some
mapping that's uh suitable for a given
state but the mapping itself is just a
user mapping interferable space so so
you have an output state in the bulk and
the input state from the boundary so
some Quantum circles so Mira is an
Einstein state which corresponds to you
take their product state in the Box it's
like every part every site is seen up
you take some direct product State and
reversely map it back to the boundary
and then you use that as an Einstein
state for your system but as a friend
pointed out so this is not really matter
this is a three tensor Network so if you
really want mirror you have this uh this
these entanglers in in in the middle
between the friends you have decent
Anglers between like these things
and uh you you can't do that you can
introduce a
sensor network with these entangles in
the same way as Mira but promoted but
but include this uh this top indices so
that this is a unitary mapping and that
will uh so so it's basically you
distribute the entanglement between the
tension Network and the residue
internally in the Box
confused by your color so are you saying
we are seeing the high energy state
where you throw away the low no we don't
throw away the law in these days we just
send them to the next layer and then
separate them again so and what we see
is the high energy yeah it's a well
it's the high energy here and the lower
and lower and lower but they're still
higher than they won't be handled at
each stage the Red Dot is Left Behind is
high energy and the low energy is pushed
upwards right so so uh
the the thing behind the wall is just a
uniform mapping there's some Quantum
Circle so you don't Define energy scale
further it's just that the output and
the input that they are they are in
common States so you talk about the
quantity low in degrees of freedom so so
so this is a coarse grain of use uh
which means you you take your your
physical degree of freedoms to build
them in half high energy here and I used
to be low energy into higher and lower
on the of that no energy yeah
so you just basically you just find a
new basis where where the new base is
nose pose still space and uh and energy
scale
so um
yeah so it may become more clear when we
go to the three formula example so so
this uh
uh once you have this mapping then then
everything uh we discussed earlier
follows that uh one way is once we map
this uh this uh system uh to the new
basis then you define a bunch of local
operators at every site and then you can
calculate this correlation function and
you use either I'm using information or
some other coordinating functions to
measure your uh your distance so so you
just repeat the same thing which you
will which you will do if you just use
the original basis and the statement is
that you're using the new business is
more meaningful it gives you some more
uh
so that's the second and then uh then
let's apply this to a very simple
example which already give you
interesting geometries so let's apply
this to the massive to the to the drumel
which may be massive or message
so so this is a one-dimensional direct
formula which is uh which is just a
discretized version of the the direct
model of the drought so you have some
linear term and a mass and then you need
to regularize the mass and then you you
replace the linear term by sine type
so so actually actually another way to
to say that is that this model is
nothing but a timer as chain I draw
earlier which is like
so so you glue these two sides as one so
there are two bands here
so it's something it's just some very
simple very simple formula chain so so
now uh let's describe let's define let's
define a unitary mapping so I I need to
Define this unit mapping which Maps the
two sides to to other sides and uh here
the mapping is very simple you just take
because you know this California has
gapless models near momentum zero so the
choice of the mapping is very intuitive
you just take the synaptic combination
of the thumbnail appearance here and
color low energy states and then you
take the anti symmetric combination
called High Energy System
so uh okay
so so you if you want to think in many
body language in the quantum Circle
language then it means that you take
this four states of the two formulas so
here you have Permian zero one and
terminal zero one then you just take the
equilateral position of the the fermion
0 1 the the states with the one chromium
and the state with zero or two formulas
are unchanged
but actually actually I also have a
speed index on each side which is this
means but the the transformation is
diagonal for that
okay so uh so what does this
transformation mean uh when we repeated
it repeat this to form the whole tension
Network
it actually uh defines a very simple
basic change because as I said this is
uh this this unitary mapping in a
serious ways just give you a new way to
do direct products position in a hero
space and uh and the unit free from your
case the new way is just a single
particle faces change because because I
have defined the mapping such that it's
quadratic it's a linear transformation
to the ferment operator so so in this
case it's just like operations form it
transforms the new basis
but here the new base is uh turns out to
be uh something you know that's called a
higher wavelength so so it's a basis
where
um it's a basis where
uh which knows both the length scale and
the position so basically if you have a
bulk if I I say I have a Permian local
here in bulk at this box site what that
means is you have a wave function on the
boundary
at this region that's related by the
tree and this will functionally the step
function like that and then if you have
a formula at a different location then
it's just a different real function with
the same shape but a different size and
different in the center Mass position
so so in a free program case in the end
this tensor Network just gives you a
wavelength transformation
and you may modify it by adding these
entire version you get a different value
rate
so so just a week ago I learned the
parameter that Steve White has some has
talked about some similar uh wavelength
Transformations and relation in terms of
network I didn't
I would I think it's probably related to
this
I want to imagine that
so so the reason why I choose this
mapping is that you can look at the low
energy so so after the first step of the
mapping every two sides is mapped to two
sides hydrogen low energy
and then uh
remember this tensor Network just give
me a uniform mapping it doesn't Define
the state so so the the this blue size
the lowest size actually coupled to each
other because the inside are a couple of
each other so you Maple this single
chain problem to two chains of the low
energy and high energy chains and then
you see that uh that if you only look at
the blue the lower energy change their
Dynamics is actually described by a
hamiltonian that has the same form as
before except the mass is the normalized
to become bigger so so that that's why
it looks like this is a reasonable real
space RG procedure and when you do this
your low energy effective Theory
is uh you're learning effect theory is
just like uh we normalize the
hamiltonian but uh but but the
difference from real space Rd is now we
have this high energy space and and we
allow entanglement between different
Energies scales which is essential for
this geometry
so
so now uh let's uh study numerically
correlation functions between these
different ball points and that will give
us a measure of the the about geometry
so uh
let's first start from the message
Theory so in the massive Theory actually
by this construction because the lawyer
effective hamiltonian Remains the Same
from as the series Remains the Same
average Step except for
overall Factor
and it is effective energy scale then
actually this correlation function in
the bulk has a scale environment so so
it's not surprising that when you
calculate the difference between
different points you can actually
recover the hyperbolic space metric
because of scale environments and we can
actually fit the metric by uh by the
formula of this geologic distance in
hyperbolic space to get the to get the
value of the
ads readers the curvature readers of the
hierbolic string
so you calculate this correlation
functions and take a log that defines
your distance you compare that with the
distance in the hyperbolic space and
that tells you that the curvature radius
is something like Point history
in the unit of light is constant
which is reasonable because
uh
in every site I mean when you have a
lattice in the area space in the site in
the region of the size of ads readers
there is always the number of sites
units is always about what you cannot
put too many things in there
so you'll compare that you can compare
the distance in both radio Direction and
and the angle Direction
and the the more okay you can also
calculate the time Direction but the
more interesting thing is when you go
away from this critical State I mean the
one one reason I want to to do this uh
this uh this mapping which is the
generalization of the mirror and his
tensor networks is that uh I don't like
when I change from one state to another
I don't want to just change by hand this
tensor Network say I have a shuffle in
Eternal state which means this this tend
to network through the end at some scale
that's what people usually say but I
don't want to do that by hand I want to
I want this network this geometry to
automatically emerge from your state so
here if you keep the same mapping as
before
uh but uh but again for the different
state say say I consider a finite
temperature thermodynamic Matrix so now
I have a new set of correlation
functions uh just Korean one can behave
differently so when you define the
geometry in the same way as before you
get a different geometry on the boundary
then uh
this uh this different this new geometry
has some interesting feature so so now
let's first look at this ratio operation
and then we look at time Direction so
the special correlation we know at the
finite temperature will Decay
exponentially in in the flat space
distance so we're going to take a log
and Define the distance in this way then
the distance will grow linearly so in
the in the ads case it's log now now you
see it's log in the shuttering and the
Crossovers linear at laundering
and that's uh that's telling you that
there is some scale in the center
because the closer you go to to the
center uh the the more you get a flat
space distance rather than hairabolic
space so when you have two points that
are nearby is like parabolic space and
we have two points that are far away you
get this uh this different shape of the
geodesic distance and actually you can
you can you can measure this uh this
what I what is actually a size of a
black hole so it means that uh this
geometry looks like a topological looks
like a disk like this this uh this tree
it looks like uh you have a disk found
in your your boundary system but the
weather is actually a disc or not it's
not determined by that picture is behind
by the correlation function right so I
can actually
look at here and walk around this circle
and then uh measure the parameter which
is like an area by measuring the
distance of nearby coins and then some
algorithms right so at a zero
temperature if you do that you get some
parameter which will Decay when you go
further and further away to the center
but in the final temperature because
this sides are less and less correlated
when you go to the center you actually
get a you actually see this parameter
Cipher is to a finite value
so so you actually see something like
this like the the parameter when you
walk around this this Center region
microsaturates to a finite value so that
means this base time this race has been
broken up and then there is a hole in
the center
although although it looks like a tree
but when you walk around it you see
there is a final parameter that you
cannot you can now go shorter so so this
geometry is actually outside here is
seriously
but this hasn't taught me why is that
black why is I mean it tells me there is
a hole why is that a black hole so so
you can see that's a black hole because
you can measure the
you can measure the times you argument
correlation we know a blackout Horizon
has this very special property that it's
a single side it's a light like surface
right when you jump in the miracle you
cannot go out so so so another way to
say that is you when you jump into the
black hole someone from outside will see
just giving it relative you see you slow
down and then all all your signal you
send out will be given the real shifted
so that's exactly what you can check
here by calculating the time Direction
correlation so you calculate Korean
function between two points that are uh
that are the same special location but
different type so uh I I don't have any
animation so I calculate uh I calculate
uh just a single particle correlation
and then you see that when you go
further and further to the inside to the
infrared region then the correlation
grows slower and slower
and there is actually a region in the
center where the correlation Almost
Doesn't grow
sorry the correlation Almost Doesn't
Decay so when you translate it into the
distance the distance Almost Doesn't
grow
so what that means is this is the
measure time so imagine time is a circle
it means there is a infrared region
where the circle is almost Vanishing the
radius of the circle is always like
almost Vanishing that's exactly what
happened near the black hole right
because you so and and the physically
here this gives you a very intuitive
into interpretation why finite
temperature state is due to a black hole
because uh because you separate the
degrees for them into energy scale and
we have a final temperature there is a
region in our system which has energy
scale small much smaller in temperature
so in fact effectively that region of
the universe is in high temperature
limit
so consequently there is no marginal
time Evolution so when no time Evolution
it's like do you have Evolution to even
a dimensional content given the
temperature then the Matrix which is one
so so there is no much time Evolution
which tells you that uh this unit
reaction
comes from
uh
so
so you so you'll see that even from this
free from your state we can't actually
read out this uh interesting uh geometry
like a black hole and you can actually
try different geometries we I will
because I'm running out of time I will
skip more of the detail of other
geometries but uh
oh uh what this is one thing I want to
mention is uh this neutral region
although every site although every site
is a very little entangled with each
other they actually entangle strongly
with the thermal pass so they actually
have a there's a maximum entropy so you
see that uh this uh the black hole
entropy here uh appears as a entry of
each site which is the internal energy
of each side with the with the thermal
path in this strategy Horizon region so
so you can study a different geometry
it's like a massive state where you see
there is a spatial boundary but not by
the time the running doesn't have human
rescue so it's like a confined geometry
where where the geometry ends at some
scale and then you can actually further
study the black hole by uh turning on
um but by by considering a two chains
which are entangled with each other so
this is called the thermal double state
where the whole system is uh the whole
system is uh uh is a pure state but if
you look at only one system uh it's a
you know thermal Ensemble then when you
look at this stage then you can do the
same mapping for both of them then that
actually tells you directly that you can
calculate the distance between these two
points you can calculate the distance
which are right between two points that
are right on top of each other then
you'll see that there are distance is
extremely small in the region in the
infrared and that's telling you that
there is a wormhole formed between these
two disks so at zero temperature there
are two disks each of them is a
hydraulic space and at the final
temperature there is this Wormhole from
and uh and that's exactly uh
inconsistently with the classical
picture of a two-sided black hole when
you have a inside crossing bridge and
you can actually start a more
interesting geometry is like the quantum
Crunch and so uh geometry
so uh
that's a
so instead of talking more about this
geometries let me briefly comment on
this uh in writing system which may be
more relevant to the to to this uh this
Workshop uh one one or two minutes so um
so I mean so far I have been applying
this mapping to a free system and then
so racism of course we don't need to we
know how to solve it so the only
interesting thing is you can read out
some interesting geometry from it but
for from a small class as a matter of
motivation you would want to use this as
a way to describe the interacting
systems so so if you want to describe if
you want to use this mapping as a way to
describe a hearing system it's basically
like applying it as a generalization of
mirror then uh what you want to do is
you want to reverse this mapping and
start from some box State method back to
the boundary and use that state you get
as an Einstein state if you start from
direct product State and then maybe you
use some disentanglers in the network
then that's the Mera state so now the
new possibility we have by modifying
this map into unitary mapping the new
possibility we have is we can introduce
a box states that is shortly range in
Tangled but there is not a direct
product for example we can use the free
from unboxing which is charging in
Tangles and uh and and that's that's the
new possibility that's allowed by this
approach and uh and there is a color
cone structure in the center network uh
which uh tells you that that it's
efficient to calculate coordinary
functions between two boundary points if
you know a way to calculate the popular
reduced dynamic so in general if you
have a box set which we don't know how
to calculate reduce standard Matrix then
it's very hard to do anything but the
statement is that if you have a box
State say free from your state for which
you know how to calculate reduce that
metrics of this regime then the boundary
State correlations are all determined
and as an interesting consequence of
that uh so this is just showing the
house this is just showing just proving
the statement I was saying that that
actually the boundary video type metrics
is determined by the bulk reducing
American everything
so so then the interesting consequence
is you can actually study a scale in
very Network and directly calculating
scaling dimensions in the same way as in
Mera and then you can plot the scale
domain instruction and the difference
from mirror is that you have this box
state so your skin dimensions of the
operators is determined by the mapping
which are these triangles and the Box
state so even if my markings are very
simple I can I can have a lot of
operators because of my box State say my
box state is even if my box set is like
a free from this uh it can give you a
big tower of uh of uh signal dimensions
so this is some numerics
this is done by e-jam or a post office
so you see the uh you get a nice Tower
of scaling Dimensions at least the at
least the counting is correct for lower
dimension lines and this is just this is
not so this is not so natural yet this
is just restoring the behavioral free
from here but now once you have this you
can generalize it to interacting systems
so you can calculate these scaling
dimensions of operators
so that's all I wanted to say and in
summaries it's a it's a new it's a new
way to try to understand the geometry in
relation to concrete entanglement and uh
also on way to describe a sound
recording systems of course there's a
lot of other questions like the relation
to the well-known idea CLT approach and
login limit
thank you
um
so the free pronoun Theory
is a proposal to be due to has been a
gravity Theory which has uh which has
given a number of fields one one per
each screen
so uh I so the relation of this approach
to that is not a clear yet but my
conjecture is this freezer so what I get
is a
but the conjecture is this so so so we
have this uh
three dimensional free from here on the
boundary
and then uh what I propose here is is a
bill to a deep large one dimensional
also free from now in the ads space and
then there is the other proposal that if
you only look at the the say you take a
this to be open vectors and then if you
only look at our singular
sector this is what serious about city
of theory which has even a number of has
been filled so uh so the conjecture is
that this thing when you just projected
to the singular sector it actually gives
you the same Theory
so the statement is that you have this
unit number of hasbian fields which are
all interacting with each other but
actually that's just because you are
looking at a free Theory uh uh you are
looking at a sub sector of a free Theory
which contains these bilinear operators
that are singulated so it's like it's
like high random organization like you
instead you insist to describe a free
from free formula for me liquid by uh by
looking at this target operators then
it's very complicated interacting model
what the goal is I mean there could be
like you say a new approach to studying
external correlative systems like we do
in sensor product States and so on but I
mean is the goal also to understand the
space-time geometry somehow because I
mean you're putting in some geometry
right you put in the basic hamiltonian
okay that maybe has local interaction in
1D but then it's critical so it
generates it realizes a new geometry but
you put in some
you know physical geometry so I mean you
know that's a bit artificial I would say
right right and the other question is I
mean you can get something new but
the other question I think is like okay
can I get any geometry I mean how about
William kovski geometry did you I mean
euclidean okay but I mean is this some
general formalism or is this sort of a
coincidence that oh hey the mirror and
the ads that matches all right that's
what I don't see well so I think
systematically yeah
related the same question so how do you
know that you mentioned
from just a tensor Network you have to
input I don't think you can emerge in
the dimension although it is a manifold
at all okay so I I don't I mean I
certainly don't have a complete answer
to these questions but uh but uh if you
I mean this approach is trying to go
towards these directions I mean and so
so come so previously I mean the
relation of tensor Network and the
geometry is like UT Square time the
geometry you know it has a network so so
here I mean it's true that it I mean
when you choose this mapping uh it's
like choosing a background geometry to
expand around like it's not a background
independent approach yeah but uh um
uh yeah so so so the okay so I'm still
in the first question you're asking so
so about the first question uh so here
the approach of starting from a boundary
State and then choose this mapping and
then get the box State it's basically
like a discrete version of you give me
the boundary condition and then uh I I
start from a background geometry that I
choose and then uh I know the quantum
fluctuations around that geometry so so
when I choose this mapping maybe it's
like I choose this background geometry
to be ads but then uh the conversation
can tell me that if my boundary
condition is different then I get a
different geometry like a black hole so
so it's like a first order perturbation
it's like it's not background
independent but let's start from home
background I know where to go I know
where is the correction so that's just
one step did better than just drawing
the network and say that's my state so
so I think let's go into that direction
but it's not a certainly not background
independent
yet so uh the second question about
other geometries uh
it seems natural to get a higher quality
obviously because I want my boundary
degree freedom to map to the bulk so so
if it's not harmonic then there seems to
be too many degree frames in about but
on the other hand uh it may not be uh
when we try to you know one thing I'm
doing now is uh we're trying to
generalize this to Continuum formalism
and by doing and the way to do that is
you have to introduce auxiliary degrees
of freedom to fill in this empty space
so in the end what you get is a series
that looks like living in deep as one
Dimensions which may be flat or maybe
hyperbolic depending on the metric it
lives in the department Dimensions but
actually the physical algorithm which
has natural Dynamics is only a bit
dimensional so so it's not clear to me
uh I mean it seems that it's possible to
cook up some Cardinal functions that
gives me a flat space or the students
based correlation it doesn't seem to
have any principle which uh
against that but I don't have an example
yeah
but you certainly can get different
geometries like if I give up if I have a
free premier liquid then it will be a
very different geometry so the
correlation behaves very differently
yeah but the dimension uh about the
dimension then it's a
well you have different ways Define
Dimension it will Define a host of
dimensions and then there is certainly a
way to calculate it and I have the
distance so you can you can calculate
the host of dimension
uh yeah well I guess it's the infinity
here because all right
here because the the volume scales like
it's not your functions
which is true for all the hydraulic
spaces but if you if you have but well
you're something better than that right
you can calculate the
well you probably need to restrict your
lab settings
schedule yeah there's nothing you have
to do
well well it's like a self-consistent
approach like I draw this lattice which
is like a discretization of some manual
but uh if you don't do it correctly then
in the end your distance for from
correlation function may give you a
completely different thing but what but
what I make is like the first first
other probation well the case when it
makes sense is uh is when when your
correction is not
to
severe that like you have a classical
geometry given by this lattice and then
the the correlation
tells you that your real geometry is
something nearby
usually the kids because nearly
classical
here of n equals one I guess yeah so so
that's a very good question so uh the
statement is not the geometry is radical
it's a it's basically like yeah it's
like you you you make some coordinate
Choice by depending on the map and in
that according to your choice you can
consider it on average geometry your
geometry is
higherbolic so if you have a Methodist
Theory and the fact that the geometry is
not semi-kinetical is shown in the fact
that the fluctuations in that box Theory
is all free from you there is no
graviton or anything so in other words
if you create a gravity in the Box it
will immediately Decay into three
formula so that's a signature that tells
you that there is a lot of quantum
flight division because there is no
values but the statement is just that
there is a lot of like this youngster is
far from
classical doesn't mean it must be very
complicated it can be just a straight
from you this three formula in the Box
plays the role of gravity
but of course it's very interesting how
do I take some larger elements and
really this needs to be covered it's
more familiar because
in The Living Model is also a piece of
RG right in
the instructions
yeah so this one is very similar to one
uh yeah but I thought you don't really
need a mirror because
because it's like it's something with
zero chord isn't it
right exactly that's my question what
can you well I mean they're they're easy
to stay with the correlation description
uh it um
I think I think that's a case where the
Box state is completed your product
state
uh yeah I know there is a rigorous
mapping there is a there's a rigorous
way to write down the level when at the
mirror State and that means America said
here in my case translate into a
statement at the bulk keyword Freedom
has no entanglement between each other
by the mapping Network
and and I think for a model because the
correlation lens is zero so you so you
actually have nothing interesting in the
box so basically you can just finish
your mapping in one step
you know your geometry is uh
is combined I mean it's like it's like
all the all the massive systems right
what you really need is just some finite
size of the mapping you don't really
need to continue
and if you insist to continue you will
see that the sites here are all
non-corrected so the geometry I guess
will be all these things are
are points that are disconnected each
other so the only interesting geometry
in this region which is when you
renownalize the finite coordinates to
zero correctness
so what happens if you use a Fermi
liquid status input with this mapping
you get anything sensible do you need to
use a different typical things I think
eventually I need a different mapping uh
so basically if I use this mapping what
I see is something like
uh we did that but um
I don't accept this answer to
be completely meaningful but
you got something like that
you have some geometry with a strong
because because this mapping is
separating degree firming into landscale
it's not really a end of the scale you
know land skills
and the further you are for me on the
low energy language is low energy but
for if I have a finite common potential
I can apply the same mapping then a lot
of these things are not long wavelengths
it's some kind of wavelets so it's
something like that so so here here at
some point I will answer the correlation
is the most long range so when you
translate to distance it's the most
smartest
shortest distance
and then then later there is another
areas here
which tells you that low energy there is
some areas correlation as long as there
is some power operation
so but but I think to really have a
better description we need to go to
Continuum limit because in general how
income area from your wavelength and uh
and this kind of wavelength approach
cannot really capture cannot really
describe this correctly nomination group
procedure for families
oh
so I guess this procedures must use sort
of the market is simpler than
it's simple it's something when the box
here is simpler yeah right sure
well the general reason is the Box area
is a sharpening quality we have a career
function with decades exactly
so that's why I mean if we have better
understanding to massive States than
methods then hopefully that works I mean
for example what people do in awclt is I
mean also here like according the skin
and dimension is translated to math in
the bulk
so it sounds easier to tune the mess
than tuning in the scanning
Let's uh thank xiaomiang and all the
speakers today